in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on deutsche welle find out
more about what's new in medical
treatment alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape and with me the
studio today is Professor balcom vitamin
he's liver specialist at the charity
University Hospital here in villain dr.
vitamin hello and welcome to the show
the patient we just saw in the report
wasn't overweight or obese but still
were suffering from the fatty liver
disease so why is that I think three
issues probably we have to consider one
major reason is definitely alcohol no
doubt about that and then I think
secondly we definitely have also a
number of metabolic diseases that we
have to consider regardless if the
patient is obese or not and that's
mainly diabetes and secondly also some
diseases that relate to the lipid
metabolism and thereby patients may
delivered develop liver disease to the
extent that they finally over years even
move into a cirrhosis of the liver okay
so it says a lot about nutrition like
alcohol sugar and fat so it's more about
more or less lifestyle so if i change my
lifestyle could have been just cure
fatty liver disease as long as you do it
in early stages definitely yes the
problem is we as you'd mentioned before
do not feel our liver to the extent that
we know that we go through a long face
of fatty liver disease and eventually
end up in a stage where the liver
already becomes fibrotic and maybe even
end up being cirrhotic and then when it
comes to alcohol how much is okay can I
drink any alcohol at all or is it every
tiny amount dangerous to my liver well I
think we can be puristic and say
probably alcohol is not good by all
means but on the other hand I think if
you look at the wh 0 criteria we have to
differentiate between women and men men
are allowed to drink more alcohol and we
talk about 20 to 30 grams per day and in
women it's 10 grams less over 10 to 20
20 grams per day meaning that you
probably can drink a glass of alcohol
and that means you if you consider that
for a period of a week you can drink
five days a glass of wine and just
should stop also for two days during the
week so it's not even one glass of wine
per day one does of wine per day would
be too much over a week yes and if I
would drink a lot of alcohol over the
weekend is it ok to use drain from
alcohol over the next week so can
deliver regenerate I think you have to
give you live at least a rest then for a
longer period in order to regenerate are
there any early warning signs for fatty
liver disease that the patient can
recognize to say ok now I have to go to
see my doctor no I think the problem is
the moment that is he starts we do not
feel it and the only way to check it is
in the first place to have some blood
drawn and in the second place also you
need some kind of image of the organ and
that is by ultrasound that's your
cheapest way and if you have some kind
of ideas a doctor that the liver is
fatty and also the blood values are
raised then you may go for a more
defined diagnostic even up to a biopsy
we got a viewer question from China yen
slip tells us that he's got fatty liver
disease and he's very concerned about
the long-term consequences so what are
long-term consequences of fatty liver
disease well I think if you have it over
a long period that means you talk about
decades and even longer you get some
kind of scary changes of the liver in
the long term chronic inflammation and
with that you may even end up with roses
of the liver and even further you may go
into a state where the liver becomes
cancerous and there of course you are in
the end stage of a long long ongoing
inflammatory disease until now happy ttc
was and it treated with a cocktail of
some antiviral drugs and humid you
laters so so what's so special about
this news of hospital the new drug is
really a breakthrough as we just heard
in the contribution first of all I think
we have a drug that has by far less side
effects and previous therapies and on
top of it it's a therapy that only is
given for three months rather than 12
month in the past and
with that we really have a breakthrough
that will be even potentiated and be
stronger once we have in fall another
drug that is given together with the
sofosbuvir and with these two agents we
can more or less eliminate more than in
ninety percent of the cases the virus in
all patients so hepatitis C gets curable
and it's a very short period of time
with low side effects but it's this kind
of treatment appropriate for all kind of
hyper GG c patients as far as the data
we have so far of course the drug hasn't
been used in a large number of patients
but with the studies so far at hand it
looks as if we probably will be able to
eliminate almost all their patients with
the viral disease in their liver so
that's really a breakthrough and we have
two golden bullets if you wish so to
cure the patient hopefully in earlier
stages and not as only in late stages
inhabited c has been a huge challenge
for medical science but most common and
dangerous form of viral hepatitis is
hepatitis B and we got a viewer question
Ramez Leon from Venezuela asked how
people get infected with hepatitis B
well I think first of all I think you
have the issue that close physical
contact is of one of the major causes of
transmission then we have the blood road
that is especially an issue for drug
users drug abusers and finally we have
causes that we do not know and they all
together cause for the other causes for
the disease so how can you protect
yourself from from catching hepatitis B
so I mean with intercourse it's usually
using a condom and the other things you
can produce yourself to not get
hepatitis B well I think the most
important issue is that we have a means
to immunize patient and with the
immunization but that is of course given
now in most countries too young other
lessons we have a chance to prevent the
disease and of course that's the best
measure also with regards to cost
effectiveness one of the best measures
we have at hand once the disease has
developed and we are in a chronic stage
in usually a fifty percent of the
infected individuals we have to treat
the patients in
this case still with interferon as I
just mentioned by in patients with
hepatitis C we do not have to use
interference anymore but here we use
interference and together with some
agents that are called nucleoside
analogs that interfere with rival viral
replication and by interfering with the
virus replicating and being more and
more in the blood we have means also to
block the disease by just eliminating
the virus so you can treat it but but it
is curable so a cuckoo from Miami you
can't answer me again can curate this
not in all cases and not in such high
percentages in hepatitis C nowadays but
I think you can cure it in have about
fifty to sixty percent but those are
major breakthroughs amazed and thank you
so much for being with us in the studio
thinking
you